-Our next guest
is the Emmy-nominated creato
and star of
the Netflix series "Special.
The second and final seaso
is streaming now.
Let's take a look.
-What are you working on?
-I'm actually kind of
having a --
a writer's block moment
right now.
-But our new work space
has an inspiration tepee.
Have you not been?
-Oh!
Yes, many times.
I-I love it there.
I just, um...
I guess it's just true
what they say, you know?
It's harder to create
when you're happy.
-You're not happy?
-Um, no, I-I am.
I'm -- I'm very happy.
-Really?
Because it's been two months
since you spoke to your mother
-Please welcome to the sho
Ryan O'Connell.
How are you, Ryan?
-Hi!
Oh, my God.
So nice to meet you on Zoom,
the way God intended!
-I agree with that 100%.
Hey, congratulations on
the second season of the show.
You play a character who is ga
and has cerebral palsy.
That is true of you, but this is
a very fictionalized character
What would you say
are the differences
between you
and the character you play
-Well, Seth, my character
lost his virginity at 28,
and I lost my virginity,
not to brag, at 17.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you so much!
That's very meaningful.
He also lived with his mom
till he was 28,
very Norman Bates vibes.
And I moved out at 18,
right on schedule.
So, I would say
he's kind of the goof troop.
You know what I mean?
And I feel like, emotionally
I was, like, the goof troop,
but outwardly projected
a sense of confidence.
-This is obviously
a really personal project,
as evidenced by the fact
that you wrote
the entire first season
by yourself.
One of the nice luxuries
of your second season is,
you had a writing staff.
Did it make the experience
different for you?
-Oh, my God.
Are you kidding me?
Writing it by myself, like
deleted years off my life.
I was, like, full twitching.
Like, not good.
No, it was amazing,
because I got to delegate.
Like, I got to, like --
It basically felt like
being on a Club Med vacation
And I feel like
just being able to, like,
widen the scope of the show,
so it wasn't just me, me, me
was really useful, as well
-You, as a kid, had a sense that
you wanted to be in television
so much so that you would
actually try to break down
what television shows
you were watching
had for A, B, and C plots
on any given week?
-Sure. I mean, the underneat
to this anecdote is, of course
I'm a genius,
I'm a child prodigy.
I'm a wunderkind.
Yes, I mean,
"90210" was my favorite.
And I think it's because
I grew up kind of, like,
blue-collar Ventura.
Do you know the movie -- the
iconic movie "Erin Brockovich"
-Of course.
-Well, I'm gonna give you
a little bit of tidbit
information and tell you
that "Erin Brockovich"
was filmed on my street.
Like, the house of
Julia Roberts' character.
And I remember when we got
the notice, I got so excited
I was like, "Julia Roberts
is gonna be on our street!
Oh, my God!
This is amazing!"
And then, all of the sudden,
it dawned on me, and I said,
"Mom, is she poor in the movie?"
[ Laughter ]
And my mom just,
like, truly, like,
the color draining from her face
just, like, shook her head
and said, "Yes."
And then, of course,
I watch it opening day
with popcorn, so excited.
My gay ass thrilled.
And then she's, like --
Here's Julia Roberts
stomping on roaches
and barely making her rent
And I'm like, "Okay. Well,
not glamorous, but love it."
[ Both laugh ]
-Were you someone that, as
you were going through school,
did you have a sense that yo
were one of the funny ones
-Yeah, I mean, I feel like
I realized I was funny
when I also realized how deepl
unfunny everyone was around me
-Sure, yeah.
-I think having
that point of comparison.
No, but, I mean, look,
being born gay and disable
in this world, you kind of
realize you need some, like,
Houdini tricks
to get through it.
Like, I was like, "Okay!
This world wasn't built for me
Let me get a machete
and just whack my way through.
So, yeah, I very much realized
that, like, I needed
to look at life through
a LOL lens
or else it was gonna
be very, very bleak.
-Your show, obviously,
provides representation
for people that have maybe never
seen a character
like themselves on television.
You were not lucky enough
to have that.
Are you getting feedback
from people
that it means a lot to them?
-Oh, absolutely.
I mean, yeah, growing up,
it was definitely like graspin
at Coke straws for anything.
I was just like --
Anything that had, like,
the slightest look of gay,
I was, like, latching onto it.
So, yeah, I mean,
people are --
You know, the response
has been really overwhelming
I just -- I want to make
something that, you know,
I would have saved thousands
of dollars in therapy
if this show had existed
when I was a teen.
So, hopefully I'm saving someone
else thousands of dollars.
A boy can dream.
-You've talked a lot about
how you wanted the show
to have realistic sex scenes
which I imagine
is always difficult
and probably even more so
when you're shooting
during a pandemic.
-Yeah, but, babe, I'm gonna di
on the gay sex hill and just
like -- [ Laughs ]
I'm just gonna go out and say,
like, I was not, like,
willing to compromise
on the sex scenes.
It's very much
in the DN-Gay of the show.
So, like, we still did it.
By golly.
You know, I never realized I was
gonna have to take that term
"I will die for my art"
so literally.
But that's where I found myself.
And, yeah, I mean,
gay sex representation
is super important to me.
I fell like growing up,
it was either, like,
heavily eroticized porn vibe
or it was like,
closeted in the woods,
spit for lube, don't look.
You know what I mean?
And I just felt like --
You know, I feel like I've bee
having gay sex for a long time
and I think I'm doing it right
And, you know, no one had
really shown it the way
I've been experiencing it,
which is funny, painful,
awkward, sexy,
all within the same thrust
You know what I mean?
-Well, I'm glad that
you hewed to your principles
and did what you wanted to do.
And congratulations, again
on the show.
Congratulations on season two,
and thanks so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-The second and final season
of "Special" is streaming now.